the Justice Department is using a new
cybersecurity test force to fight
foreign attempts at election
interference the group will also try to
slow down the aggressive cyber attacks
coming from Iran
tonight correspondent Jillian Turner on
the growing threat and some breaking
news about what what one American
company is doing Fox News exclusively
confirms that Google has shut down an
Iranian backed app called telegram black
and banned its developer from Google's
platforms this is US officials ring
alarm bells about Iran waging cyber
warfare against the United States
frankly the United States is under
attack
it's the latest move as the American
government and American companies are
taking on this emerging threat from the
Islamic Republic just yesterday the
Attorney General launched a new
cybersecurity task force that will go
after foreign criminal adversaries
Google banned the Iranian government
spyware app after the National Council
of resistance of Iran issued an alarming
new report it exposes how Iran's
military has manipulated mobile apps to
surveil thousands of its own citizens
the report warns that Western countries
are now in the Iranian regime sites they
have a unit called the Intelligence
Organisation and specific Department
allocated to the cyber warfare this is
the department that deals with the cyber
warfare against the Western countries
but also most recently against their own
population for years the Iranian regime
has run a very public messaging campaign
against the Western world targeting its
main enemy the United States in December
a massive public protest ignited in
Tehran and quickly spread to many of
Iran's major cities as they unfolded the
US Intel community began to suspect Iran
was using spyware to locate and then
arrest protesters US investigators
discovered that Iran was also trying to
find ways to spy on Americans while
Russia China Iran and North Korea poses
the greatest cyber threats Iran will try
to penetrate u.s. and allied networks
for espionage and lay the groundwork for
future cyber attacks so while most
Americans have been focused on Iran's
nuclear threat the Trump administration
has been grappling with the threat of
cyber warfare behind the scenes this new
threat is another factor on the
president's mind as he decides whether
or not to recertify the nuclear deal in
only a few weeks Brett
Gillian thank you